[Applaudissements]
23 novembre 2006 paris à la sortie du
parc des princes pour la première fois
en france un supporters meurt à la suite
d'un match de foot
un groupe de parisiens pour suis un fan
de l'équipe israélienne de tel aviv un
policier en civil tentent de le protéger
prends peur tirs julien quemener un
supporter parisien de 25 ans fréquentant
la tribune de boulogne est mort
face au drame une partie de la tribune
boulogne est fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
boulogne la tribune des supporters
ultras du paris saint germain
celle qui cristallise les peurs en
raison de la violence des supporters qui
la fréquentent
mais qui sont vraiment ces supporters
qui peuplent cette partie du stade
quelle est cette violence qui s'y
manifeste
comment at-on pu en arriver là
stéphane fréquente depuis 15 ans cette
tribune avec son coeur ses points
loin du stéréotype du supporters
violents bombers chaussures coq et crâne
rasé lui à 30 ans fan du psg depuis plus
de 20 ans
quand on annonce qu'on pourrait penser
je suis pas du tout un art finale donc
on peut voir mon univers professionnel
je suis je travaille la direction des
ventes des grandes sociétés françaises
pour très bien mon travail des
directeurs de grandes sociétés
internationales voilà c'est mon
quotidien professionnel
cadres d'entreprises la semaine il se
transforme le week-end en willing and
supporters indépendants et imprévisible
dont quoi le fait d'évoluer dans ce
milieu professionnel
je côtoie selon l'opinion publique des
gens très respectables d'avoir des
les responsabilités professionnelles ça
m'empêche pas d'aller toutes les
semaines au parc des princes données du
coup de poing avec ma famille du kop de
boulogne
nous avons donc voulu en savoir plus et
pénétrer en caméra cachée au sein de
cette tribune qui fait tellement peur
nous avons très vite compris que nous
n'étions pas les bienvenus et que
personne ici n'avait envie de parler aux
journalistes
si nous voulions découvrir le vrai
visage de la tribune boulogne il
faudrait nous en remettre aux images
filmées par les supporters eux mêmes
des images qui vise à faire peur à
impressionner le camp adverse
voici donc boulogne sa légende son
histoire ses règles ses codes raconté de
l'intérieur par ceux qui la vivent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tribune boulogne c'est la seule tribune
française reconnue et respectée
en europe entière voire dans le monde
[Applaudissements]
le psg et les fans de la tribune
boulogne doivent impérativement à
agir en fonction cette réputation
[Applaudissements]
une réputation qui s'est écrite au fil
des années des générations de supporters
et des combats livrés stéphane intègre
la mouvance très jeune et ne tarde pas à
vivre son baptême du feu version
hooligans
moi c'est simple la première fois
j'avais 16 ans je suivais 2 les fans du
paris saint germain quand déboulé devant
nous deux cent cinquante lyonnais
attention hooligans mode d'emploi voici
comment les membres du kop de boulogne
pensent et agissent
[Musique]
pour toute la provence là vous voyez là
c'est les supporters de nice en face
pour tous les supporters provinciaux
le paris saint germain c'est nous c'est
boulogne 6 éoliennes et c'est pas une
équipe de foot totalement
une liste blue ligue à nice mme dans son
idée on se bat à nombre égal avec des
règles des codes c'est peu ou prou du
sadomasochisme c'est à dire que c'est
des individus qui décide qui aime se
battre et qui décide de se battre mais
dans un cadre excitant c'est à dire ils
vont pas forcément faire de la boxe ou
des sports de combat ils vont essayer de
se battre en bande d'une part et d'autre
part dans un cadre qui suppose de
déjouer les forces de l'ordre à tout un
jeu d'arriver à rien que d'arriver à
rentrer en contact ne serait ce que dix
secondes c'est déjà tout un tout un
processus donc c'est ça qui les excite
c'est la montée d'adrénaline
l'excitation que va procurer la bagarre
et donc on est dans une logique de
violence rechercher du lance consentis
dans les deux camps
cette violence consenti thierry l'a bien
connu supporters ultras il a pendant
plus de dix ans fréquente et la mouvance
hooligans il a réussi à s'en extraire il
ya sept ans au prix d'une thérapie et de
deux tentatives de suicide
repenti marqué au fer rouge par ses
actes ils tentent de tourner la page et
revient pour nous pour la première fois
assisté à un match de foot dans un stade
plus sur un impressionnant je serai
tranquille
on va dire que j'ai choisi les matches
aussi
moi je choisis des matches durs ou c'est
juste un match nul
cherry et elle est loin dans la spirale
du hooliganisme très loin dans la
violence aussi sans contrôle sans
conscience
retour sur son entrée en hooliganisme
c'est grâce à son magazine un que j'ai
pu aller bien plus loin à l'organisme en
fait c'était la facilité de rencontrer
des gens voient pas ce qu'il y avait le
nom il y avait la drees il y avait tout
le monde vous avez vous dit et écrit est
traîné vous correspondez
lui correspondait changement nos photos
changement de vidéos
qu'est ce que vous avez fait le week-end
dernier on est allé à tel endroit hôtel
en attendant c'est dans les anciens dans
notre centre est un groupe de nantes et
on les a mis à l'envers mois déjà me
rappeler à minuit et en disant on va te
tuer et à martigues psg on et saint
martin on va te tuer puis j'entends des
français blanche immatriculée le judas
de tout quoi intriguant c'est faire
partir d'un jeu d'accepter les cours
qu'on peut donner et qu'on peut comme
pour recevoir ces identités aussi
savoir avec avec le foot le foot c'est
une excuse pour aller se battre
facilement avec un tel groupe alain
temps d'accord moi je transfère une amie
si je prends un coup de couteau
mais bonne chance quelques cas en france
qu'il remontera sur le visage parce que
je sais que je voulais pas rater quoi
thierry rats même jusqu'à se faire
graver dans la peau holtz l'abréviation
de hooligans
c'est cette image qui va le ramener à la
raison une image qui le hantera des
nuits durant nous sommes en 1998 en
pleine coupe du monde sur le pavé
lensois le gendarme nivelles laissé pour
mort les jardins manivelle ces choses
qui nous ont tant marqué au point de vue
humain mais par terre une flaque de sang
rappelez vous dit
j'ai quand même une réaction au matin
j'ai mis le pied par terre et je me suis
dit allez j'arrête j'y le courage
d'aller faire le courage d'avoir acheté
mes chemins ce qui c'était facile a été
très difficile parce que ça fait sept
ans que ça dure
et dont il n'a fait que je fasse de ts
pour
comprendre les voir l'erreur que j'avais
fait
j'ai fait une faute très très grande
la prise de conscience de thierry lui a
permis de s'extraire de cet univers de
peur et de haine mais les générations de
supporters violents se suivent et se
ressemblent la violence s'est imposé au
fil du temps comme une composante
naturelle du monde des gradins en
particulier au sein de la tribune
boulogne
[Musique]
jean philippe d'hallivillée le monsieur
sécurité du psg
pour lui à l'intérieur du stade les
violences sont tendance à disparaître
même si les dérives racistes demeurent
courantes
on avait inventé la vivent déjà
accentuer la surveillance sur r2 qui
était historiquement un noyau un peu
plus politisés c'est vrai et les séries
the police avait accentué la répression
dans cette zone en identifiant des bras
tendus
[Musique]
des personnes qui portaient des
des t-shirts avec des croix gammées un
sigle à caractériser et caractérisable
est condamnable par la loi
plutôt que de racisme stefanou préfère
lui parler de nationalisme
idéologiquement on est effectivement
très patriotes et nationalistes
après vous avez multitude de graduation
ça va de l'ultranationaliste au simple
patriote
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nationalistes patriotes
mais ce que ces groupes de supporters
sont encadrés politiquement l'image
qu'on a c'est des groupuscules
politiques extérieures qui viendraient
infiltrés boulogne répandre leur
idéologie c'est pas du tout ça c'est la
tribune qui elle même fait sa propre
politique est globalement ceux qui ont
une idéologie raciste ou fascistes très
affirmée sont vraiment minoritaires
[Applaudissements]
même si boulogne n'est pas noyauté
politiquement elle dérange au delà même
du club c'est toute une ville qui se
retrouvent entachée par ces dérives
à l'hôtel de ville c'est pascal cherki
l'adjoint aux sports qui monte au
créneau
moi je m'en fous qui leur incombent le
rouge une primipare je vais vous dire un
truc pourquoi pas c'est le drapeau de la
république donc ce n'est pas ça la
question la question c'est le racisme
et la violence qui sont les débits là
n'est plus dans le domaine de l'opinion
donc moi est ce que les gens au niveau
je m'en fous la moitié de ce pays qui
vote à gauche ou à l'extrême gauche
moitié qu'ils votent la droite et
l'extrême droite je pense que dans un
stade vous retrouvez à peu près les
mêmes distribution mais c'est pas ça la
question ni le racisme et la violence on
n'est plus dans le domaine de l'opinion
on est dans le domaine du des lits du
délit réprimé par les lois de la
république donc c'est autre chose on est
dans quelque chose qui peut vous amener
devant le tribunal correctionnel
[Musique]
un racisme qui au fil des années à
installer une véritable ségrégation au
sein de la tribune boulogne l'apartheid
au coeur de paris
la tribune et blanche les majorettes à
mains blanches effectivement mais ce
qu'ils refusent l intégration la tribune
boulogne qui refusait ce n'est pas
la personne de couleur le black
le robot quoi que ce soit c'est
tout individu de type racaille c'est à
dire qu'il ya là même une logique quand
vous êtes blanc vous allez dans une cité
ben vous êtes quelque peu mal acceptée à
boulogne c'est exactement la logique
inverse c'est à dire que quand vous êtes
une racaille
visiteurs combattu et demi a
immédiatement
violences racistes boulogne décidément à
la hauteur de sa mauvaise réputation
mais les hooligans empêche-t-il des
autres supporters de se rendre au stade
la peur at elle gagné les familles les
enfants les jeunes désirant se rendre au
parc des princes
à plaisir dans les yvelines les enfants
du club de foot sont habités par le
conseil général
ont dans la voiture on est parti pour le
stade dès qu'il le peut salim l'acte
harry accompagne son fils sofiane au
parc des princes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sofiane qu'est-ce qui va gagner à ton
avis ce soir là
ah ouais ça je suis d'accord avec toi
les petits défauts qui gagnent paris
saint-germain quand même
c'est vrai qu'ils sont super heureux est
très enthousiaste à l'idée d'aller au
parc des princes 1 c'est
ça nous laisse nous déjà les grands
rêveurs donc les petits on n'imagine pas
mon père m'amenait étant petit donc moi
aujourd'hui qui ce qui suit par an j'ai
aucune appréhension à emmener mon fils
je connais l'ambiance du stade je sais
qu'il ya du monde
et il n'est pas prêt de céder face à
quelques hooligans
c'est pas cette petite minorité qui va
nous empêcher à nous deux qui aimons le
football d'aller ce type de rencontre à
ce type de match au contraire il faut
faire abstraction de tout ça et puis
continuer à
garder notre passion et puis à avoir à
vivre des moments comme ça qu'ils sont
là toujours extraordinaire
mais pour que tout le monde puisse
assister dans les meilleures conditions
possibles en termes de sécurité à toutes
les rencontres il a fallu sortir les
très très grands moyens
le parc des princes sous très haute
surveillance
250 supporters jugées parmi les plus
dangereux interdits de stade dans un
premier temps
170 toujours banni de tribune
aujourd'hui
2500 policiers mobilisés sur les
rencontres placées les plus a réussi un
renforcement des systèmes de sécurité à
l'entrée du stade pour rendre encore
plus efficace la fouille opérée par les
stadiers
un commissariat implantée au coeur de
l'enceinte sportive et des supporters
adverses encadrés dès leur arrivée à
proximité du parc et guider jusqu'à leur
tribune
un dispositif musclé qui permet à sa
ligne sofiane et tous les enfants de
plaisir de s'installer tranquillement
dans leur tribune les yeux grands
ouverts
regardez
quelque chose de magnifique
belle ambiance
dans les sous sols du parc les services
de police à faire à quelques minutes du
début du match ils doivent vérifier la
présence dans leur commissariat
respectives des 170 interdits de stade
une personne qui vient sont pointés à
tous les commissariats parisiens les
commissariats et les brigades de
gendarmerie de petite et grande couronne
qui nous avertissons temps réel de
l'arrivée du service interne et statuts
doivent pointer on centralise tous ici
stéphane fait partie de ces 170
interdits de stades alors comme tous les
soirs de match il a l'obligation d'être
présent dans le commissariat de son
quartier au coup d'envoi ça fait une
quinzaine d'années que je suis paris
saint-germain un peu partout
effectivement depuis trois mois
je n'ai plus besoin de mettre les pieds
dans un stade et de voir mon équipe
jouer au football le motif sur lequel
j'étais interdit de stade ses
fréquentations de la tribune boulogne
chose que je revendique mon dieu je suis
jamais passé devant tribunal pour mes
activités au parc des princes voilà pour
moi c'est une injustice là qui se
produit parfois elle est devenue points
aux abords des stades c'est un motif
pour interdire de stade pour moi c'est
du coup poing très cadré qui justifiait
pas une décision arbitraire pour moi
à 20h45 stéphane arrive donc pour
pointer
après cinq
dix
quinze minutes d'attentes il est enfin
reçu par un fonctionnaire de police
comme à tous les matchs il signe les
quatre feuillets attestant sa présence
[Musique]
la notification vivait là mais ce soir
là en plus il se voit remettre une
prolongation de son interdiction de
stade pour trois mois supplémentaires
au parc on centralise les résultats des
différents pointages pour vérifier que
personne ne manque à l'appel
si je l'aimais
c'est tout ok merci
de toute façon moi j'ai des
fonctionnaires qui sont la
vidéosurveillance donc on les connaît si
par malheur on les trouvait à
l'intérieur il se fera interpeller
rapidement
pour stéphane pas de temps à perdre le
match est déjà commencée depuis 20
minutes
comme on a vu mathieu 20h45 il me faut
pointer à
20h45 donc au coup d'envoi ils ne
gardent un quart d'heure on va dire que
j'attrape quelques matchs
mon club
jeudi
le peuple est plus près de chez moi est
à
ah bon quart d'heure vingt minutes de
voiture donc voilà c'est les bouts de
matches qu'on gagne 1
punit de trois mois d'interdiction de
stade supplémentaire il n'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi un tel acharnement
aujourd'hui je pense que dès qu'il y
aura un club de données dans un stade et
que ça passera la télé bon bah on
interdira trois mois voilà c'est ça va
être ça
dans 4
mois voire quelques années je pense
[Musique]
dans les tribunes du parc en revanche
tout se passe dans le calme et la bonne
humeur
malgré les difficultés sportives du psg
près de 40000 supporters sont présents à
chaque rencontre est apparemment pour
sofiane c'est un peu angoissant
surtout lorsque votre équipe préférée
n'arrive pas à marquer
[Applaudissements]
à
il est 21h 45 la première mi-temps est
terminée stéphane arrive enfin dans un
bar mais c'est loin bien loin de le
satisfaire ouais ce qui manque c'est
plutôt le contexte de la tribune cette
chaleur c'est voilà ouais c'est un
appartenant soit sam en quoi
c'est la consternation face à rien quoi
t'as pas de façon pas patrick enfin
j'veux pas du style à m'emballer devant
la télé avec un maillot du psg chez moi
pour moi j'ai envie de vivre le truc
vivre l'ambiance
et puis au coeur de l'action était à 10
ans donc c'est vrai que ça n'a pas la
même saveur et puis c'est que si tu
avais pas pris certaines choses
pour
être dans un stade pour quoi faire si
j'avais été dans un stade pour pour
vivre le truc de manière très calme non
non non c'est pas moi c'est pas la
passion selon
saint lô bise aux bis comme ce rallye
vélo dimanche non moi je vis a
passionnément du coeur dans la passion
et avec des raisons voilà y'a pas de
jets pas été trop loin non je pense pas
avoir été trop enduit non je crois ce
que j'ai fait je suis je pense pas avoir
été trop loin
ni regrets ni remords
du côté du parc des princes on veille le
pc sécurité pilote des centaines de
caméras pour scruter les moindres
recoins repérer d'éventuels interdits de
stade où tout comportement suspect un
travail qui porte ses fruits en 2007
aucun incident n'est à déplorer
pourtant aujourd'hui encore la tribune
boulogne continue de pratiquer une
discrimination à l'entrée alors jeunes
blacks et beurs de banlieue se retrouve
dans d'autres tribunes loin du top est
bien décidé à s'en tenir à l'écart il
vaut la vie on fait notre vie
michael
[Musique]
alors
mais séparés si c est ok pas de problème
ambiance
signal
on a des racines partout dans le monde
toi le rappeur de tous les racistes à
torcy on serait tranquille lors de tee
shirt noir a marché à hauteur du
problème a relevé me suis vite et quoi
personne ne savait ce que
lee on va parler à toulalan
triste
mais comme j'ai pas envie d'avoir des
problèmes je vais rester ici
rabat ses tribunes racines et ici
chacun chez soi
la deuxième mi temps reprend pour tout
le monde
stéphane est forcément un peu amer de ne
pas pouvoir être présent au stade et la
solitude commence à se faire sentir
[Musique]
au stade ambiance nettement plus agitée
et pour salim et son fils
suspense de tous les instants
ça
victoire finale du paris saint germain
les supporters se disperse dans le calme
après un beau match de foot
le football un sport pas forcément
coupable de tous les maux dont on accuse
et qui n'est et ne devrait rester jamais
qu'un jeu